Hi, and welcome back. Welcome to video
number eight. You survived the first seven
videos. And during this entire process,
what we've done up to this point, what
we've actually achieved is we've taken the
approach of really defining why retail
traders, the vast majority of retail
traders, lose money.
Now, by doing that, we've actually picked
up our principles along the way. The
principles of what not to do. So, the
principles of the approach of what
professional traders actually do when they
approach the financial markets.
And this is very important, and I
encourage you to try and hard code these
principles in your mind. I encourage you
to keep going back and watching those
videos to make sure that you understand
those principles fully fully. Now, what
we're actually going to do is we're going
to start to build out what we call in the
professional trading world, a systematic
asset selection process.
Now, systematic asset selection processes
are very, very important within the
industry.
When we look at our objectives here in
this series to provide you guys a
framework, retail traders, that enables
you to emulate successful professional
traders, your objectives are very much
aligned, as we've discussed, to hedge fund
managers.
Now, what you're going to see here is an
introduction to the Institute's wish
framework and the wish framework is really
a template, a template for a systematic
asset selection process.
And this template, this approach is used
by pretty much the vast, vast majority of
hedge fund managers, successful hedge fund
managers.
And you're going to realize when you watch
this video why systematic asset selection
processes are so important.
And the first thing we're going to do is
actually define what a systematic asset
selection process is.
Then, in the same video, we're actually
going to take the first step, which is to
define what type of market we're in,
whether we're in a bull market or a bear
market.
And this is important because if you
understand the landscape that you're
operating in, then you have a much clearer
idea of the bigger trend.
But it's also important because bull
markets and bear markets are often
misdefined and misinterpreted by the
mainstream media.
And the professional trading community has
a different definition of bull and bear
markets.
Now, once we've defined the systematic
asset selection process and defined which
market we're in,
we're then going to move on to the first
stage of the framework, which is idea
generation.
And idea generation is the vast majority
of your work.
This is going to take us all the way up to
video 20.
And then we move on to gatekeeping.
And then after gatekeeping, we move on to
risk management.
And then we move on to self-awareness as a
trader.
And these are the four stages of any
systematic asset selection process that
has integrity within the professional
trading community.
And this process can be used as a template
by anybody.
So the four stages are idea generation,
gatekeeping, risk management and
self-awareness.
And please pay attention to the slide
where we map out the entire process.
Get this slide in your mind and really
memorise it.
Because this is really the template of the
professional trader.
So, first thing we're going to do, define
the systematic asset selection process and
define what market we're operating in.
Once we've done that, we're going to move
on to actually building out idea
generation.
And then build out the entire process for
the rest of the video series.
Okay, let's go over to the presentation
and I'll see you at the end of the video
with a full summary.
So now, we're going to start a process
where we're going to try to manipulate
these odds in our favour.
If we can do that, then we are the
bookkeeper.
We are the bookmaker.
What you'll find is most professional
traders, crop functions, investment banks,
hedge fund managers,
they will have systematic processes that
they go through to create a situation
where the odds are in their favour.
So, what we'll do first, really, we've got
to get perspective of the historical
behaviour of the market.
As in, where we've come from.
Understand what we're dealing with at the
present.
So, you can make predictions for the
future.
So, first, what we're going to do is
define what a systematic process is and
then get perspective.
And then we move on to the next stage,
which is actually building all the
processes and the system.
So, crudely, what is a systematic process?
Going through a series of processes to
find suitable good trades or investments
with a high probability of success.
It's a process of idea generation.
Something that we call gatekeeping.
Risk management and self-awareness.
Across all the asset classes.
So, it's indiscriminate of what we're
actually going to take positions in.
So, across equities, currencies,
commodities, and bonds.
Available instruments globally, 40,000.
Out of those 40,000 opportunities, which
ones are going to give us the highest
probability of success?
So, a top-down approach.
We start at the top level of the world and
we work our way down.
A bottom-up approach is picking one asset
out of the 40,000 and just doing work on
that one asset.
Fundamental analysis of the particular
asset.
A varied approach is a mixture of both.
So, you're trying to take the best of what
works from both disciplines.
So, this, what I call the wish framework,
is essentially a varied approach.
Utilising what works from each area the
best and gives us the highest probability
of success in combining them all.
So, we're stacking the odds as high as
possible in our favour to try and make
money.
And it's adaptable to any situation.
And you'll find that it will work as a
process, probably over your entire life.
Now, it's not finite as in everything that
you see in the next day and a half.
You don't have to do any more work on top
of that.
In terms of the process, you can go away
and add things into the process.
But add things into the process at the
correct level.
So, don't deviate from the process in
future and do things in reverse.
It's the process that's the important
point here.
And this is what it looks like.
So, top left, we have idea generation.
First thing we do is we get a view on the
world.
And our world view dictates our
positioning, our bias in commodities,
currencies, bonds, and equities.
But at an index level.
If we then concentrate on the stock
market, we have to go and work from the
top down.
So, then we move on to industries within
the stock market.
And then we move to stocks within those
industries.
And then across equities, commodities,
currencies, and bonds, we then overlay
this situation with technical analysis and
price action indicators that allow us to
keep the gate closed to bad ideas and open
to good ideas.
Then, when you actually commit capital,
these positions become real.
They become part of your portfolio.
Once they're in your portfolio, you have
various risk management parameters and
tools that you can use to ensure your
downside is protected.
So, when bad things happen, you don't blow
up.
You live to fight another day.
You come back and you're stronger.
So, when you've got real positions, you
can have gross exposure limits, net
exposure limits, in the stock market,
hedge out, beta, theme limits, single
position limits, stock target ratios, and
how you deal with winners and losers.
What processes, what processes you go
through, and that's really the risk
management, having discipline.
So, making sure that when you've got real
positions, you have the discipline to do
the right things all the time.
And then, you're either going to be a good
trader or a bad trader and your statistics
will tell you whether you're good or bad.
The most important statistic is whether
you make or lose money.
But then, you can overlay this with other
statistics to find out what your behaviour
is as a trader, and you can have
self-awareness.
And I'm going to show you a tool that a
lot of hedge fund managers use to decide
whether to distribute capital to a trader
over another trader.
And that's important, simply because you
don't have a boss to tell you what to do.
So, why do the pros use systematic
processes?
It's because they have outside investors.
If they didn't rely on systematic
processes, they wouldn't get outside
investors.
Imagine going to pitch somebody for $25
million of capital to put in your hedge
fund.
And you walk up and you say, on one page,
this is what I do.
I buy and sell Eurodollar every day.
And I try to make 10 basis points.
You're not going to get $25 million.
The objective of the person giving you
that money, first of all, people have
varying objectives.
But, most of the time, it's to protect
that money in absolute terms, the value of
it, and protect against inflation.
And to be exposed to markets that go up
and down, so they can be hedged in all
situations.
That's their first objective.
So, they don't want to see somebody who
punts around.
They want to see somebody with consistent
track record, who's long short, who gets
decent returns on low volatility.
That's what an investor wants to see from
a hedge fund manager.
So, why use these systematic processes?
It's because, obviously, to try and
protect the money, and to make money, but
also to raise money.
They're never, ever going to be able to
raise money if they don't show people
their investment process, how they make a
decision.
So, technical indicators, just a few
indicators to trade aren't good enough for
these guys, then they're clearly not good
enough for us.
Like, even as retail traders, we had to
take the same approach.
And most hedge funds, the process is
really similar to what you're going to
learn today.
We put two guys into hedge funds in
November.
One guy went in in February.
And these guys were institute traders,
like, as in, trading through us, and I see
all of their positions and help them.
They were trading for about a year.
And when they got interviews at the hedge
fund, they have a starter interview, where
they don't really get any information on
the hedge fund.
If the guys like them, then they go back
for second interviews, and they get sent
the investment process at the hedge fund.
The two guys who went in in November, they
were interviewed in October, are when they
saw the investment process of this
particular hedge fund.
They rang me up and just laughed on the
phone and said, it's basically your
framework.
They're really similar.
A lot of the processes are very, very
similar.
Starting off with idea generation.
Top-down and or bottom-up approach.
Combination of both in the stock market.
Predominantly top-down in currencies,
commodities, and bonds.
So, you go through a bunch of processes
that spit out ideas.
So, it's like a machine that just spits
out ideas.
And then you've got to decide whether it's
a good time to commit capital to that
idea.
So, you overlay it with a screening
process.
And the screening process is varying
indicators to stop yourself doing stupid
things.
The worst thing in the world, as a trader,
is to go into a position.
You're right, but you get stopped out.
So, you're proved correct in all the work
that you did to generate the idea, but you
actually lose money.
That's worse than losing money when you're
wrong.
Because at least when you lose money when
you're wrong, you're wrong.
Make sense?
That's why you have screening processes.
To stop yourself doing stupid things.
So, coming up with great ideas.
I.e., to buy a stock.
That's a great idea.
But you go and buy it at the top.
And then you lose 10%.
And then it goes up 100%.
That's just crazy.
That's why you have to have a screening
process.
Risk management.
When the positions become real positions,
and there's real money at stake, making
sure that
your downside is totally protected.
And self-awareness, trader metrics, to
know when you should be deploying more
capital
to yourself, or taking capital away from
yourself.
And being very honest with yourself about
it as well.
Because the numbers do not lie.
So, that's a systematic process,
essentially.
There's thousands of hedge funds in the
world that claim to have the key to all
that amazing
investment.
But essentially, they all kind of fit
within that remit.
Idea generation.
Gatekeeping.
Risk management.
And self-awareness.
So, now we know what a systematic process
is, we can start building one.
But first, let's get perspective.
We're about to go into the market, so we
have to understand the market in another
way to what
we've looked at the market.
We have to understand where it's come
from, where it is today, where it might be
going, and what it all means.
And they're questions you should be asking
yourself all the time, every day.
Where has this market come from, where has
this market come from, where is it today,
where is it going, what is it all mean?
Train your mind into that process, that
thought process.
You should be asking yourself that eight,
ten times a day.
So, we look at historical stock market
performance, and first we want to
basically define what market we're
actually in.
Are we in a bull market or a bear market?
So, let's ask the question now.
The market that we're in now, are we in a
bull or a bear market?
Who said bull?
Yeah, we're in a bull market.
But what's the actual definition of a bull
or a bear market?
Okay.
The definition in the media, so when you
pick up a newspaper, or turn on the TV,
the definition in the media of a bear
market is a 20% fall in an index from this
year's high.
And a bull market is a 20% rise in an
index from this year's low.
So, you take this year's high, multiply it
by 0.8, goes through that level, you're in
a bear market.
Take the low of the year, multiply it by
1.2, if it goes through that level, we're
in a bull market.
Unfortunately, the media definition is not
the professional trader definition of a
bull and bear market.
So, ignore the media.
The professional trader definition of a
bull and bear market, and get on the phone
to anyone at a big pension fund on Wall
Street,
in the city, anywhere in Asia, get on the
phone to any hedge fund manager and ask
them.
They'll tell you what the real definition
of a bull and bear market is, which is a
bear market at 20% fall from the high of
the previous business cycle.
And a bull market is a rise, not of 20%
from the low of the year, but a rise back
above the bear market level that was set
in the previous business cycle.
Does that make sense?
So, let's have a look at where we are now.
So, S&P 500 on the 9th of October 07.
In the last business cycle, and by the
way, we do move on later to definitions of
business cycles, and we look at the
business cycle of the US.
9th of October 07, the S&P 500 closes on a
high of 1565 spot 1.5.
What's the bear market level?
Multiply it by 0.8.
12.52 spot 1.2.
It went through that level on the 9th of
July 08.
So, almost a year later.
Closing at 12.44 spot 6.9.
It then exited on the 21st of December
2010.
So, when the markets are really, really
quiet, just before Christmas in 2010, what
happened?
The US officially came out of a bear
market.
So, we entered a bull market on the 21st
of December 2010.
So, when everyone was buying their last
minute presents for Christmas and running
home, the US had entered a bull market.
What about the FTSE 100?
The high close, 6732 spot 4.
On the 15th of June 07.
Bear market level, 5385 spot 3.2.
On 9th of July 08.
Where have we seen that date before?
Exactly on the same day.
So, the US and the UK went into a bear
market as defined by professional traders
on exactly the same day.
Why do you think that was?
Christmas.
Sorry?
No, it's 9th of July 08.
I don't know when you celebrate Christmas.
But why do you think that happened?
Shall I tell you why?
Because the US went into a bear market, so
everyone sold everything in the world.
That was it.
So, it didn't matter what it was.
The US goes into a bear market, just sell
everything.
But it exited, the FTSE exited of the 24th
of December 09th.
So, a full year before the S&P 500.
Now, you'll probably figure out this
tomorrow, but we'll start with it now.
I'll just make the statement.
You can think about it.
The make-up of the indices, the difference
between the S&P 500 and the FTSE 100, the
types of companies in the index.
What would that suggest if we're using the
professional trading definitions of
following the business cycle to determine
bull and bear markets?
What would that suggest about the make-up
of the index of the FTSE relative to the
make-up of the index of the S&P 500?
The types of companies that are in and
make up the index.
The make-up of the companies in the FTSE,
the earnings of those companies are more
sensitive to the business cycle overall
than the make-up of the companies in the
US.
So, when the business cycle turns, what
goes first?
Because the cyclicals go first.
So, the FTSE is made up relative to the
S&P 500 of sensitive earnings compared
when you compare across.
The S&P 500 is a much broader index
representing 500 companies and a higher
percentage of defensives relative to
cyclicals.
What about the DAX?
Started selling off 16th of July, 07.
Bear market level 6484, spot 55.
Reached in March, 08.
Again, earlier than the FTSE.
Sorry, earlier than the S&P, but later
than the FTSE.
Why do you think that was?
We can rationalise all this in hindsight.
Subprime crisis.
Very bank heavy.
So, now we know what a bull and a bear
market is.
We're going to know what type of market
we're in at any one time.
If you did one thing, if you do one thing
in any business cycle, if you just short
indexes, when they break the bear market
level, or break the bull market level, go
back into a bull market and you buy them.
If you do that, if you do that, if you do
that, you'll just make money.
Because all the money that follows that
will come in and out of the market based
on that.
It happens in every business cycle.
But how do we predict that we're going
into a bull market or going into a bear
market, so you can be positioned before it
actually happens?
Well, that's the key, isn't it?
It's the key to everything.
If you can tell what's going to happen in
6 to 12 months' time, whether we're going
to enter a bear market or stay in a bull
market or go into a bull market, you're
going to make tons a night.
And if you can do that for the rest of
your life, you're going to be very, very
wealthy.
Okay, so welcome back.
Now, as you went through the presentation,
you would have realized that we looked at
a couple of things there.
First thing we looked at was defining the
systematic asset selection process and
introducing to you the Wish Framework.
And the Wish Framework as a template
really does serve as the professional
trader approach.
Now, one of the things that we mentioned
in the presentation there was that if you
want to add in anything into the Wish
Framework as we're going along, feel free
to add in anything you want.
But you have to make sure that as you're
doing it, you add in what you want to add
in at the right area of the Wish
Framework.
Now, the Framework really is a combination
of a top-down and a bottom-up approach.
Overlaid with technical analysis and price
action indicators, prudent risk management
and self-awareness statistics as a trader.
Now, we're going to go through all of the
videos up to video 20, which really is the
bulk of the work, which is idea
generation.
Then we're going to move on to
gatekeeping.
And then we have risk management and
self-awareness stats.
This map that you saw on the presentation,
please get it in your mind, but feel free
to add in anything you want to at any
stage.
If you consider yourself extremely useful
at technical analysis, then you can add in
your technical analysis, TA indicators, at
the stage of technical analysis, which is
within gatekeeping.
But please don't add it into idea
generation.
This will all become clear later why.
So, the first thing we did was we defined
the systematic asset selection process and
introduced you to the Wish Framework.
The second thing we did in this
presentation was to define bull and bear
markets.
Now, why are we doing that?
We're doing that to really just get
perspective and a snapshot of where we are
at any one point in time.
So, now at any moment in your life, now
you have these definitions, you can look
over the markets globally and just define
exactly what markets you're in by using
the professional trader definition of bull
and bear markets,
not the populist media definition of bull
and bear markets.
So, now that we've defined the systematic
asset selection process, you've seen an
introduction to the Wish Framework, the
professional trader template,
and we've defined what type of market
we're in, now we can actually move on to
predict what type of market we're going to
be in in the future.
Because that's what professional trading
is all about.
It's not reacting to what's in the
mainstream media right now.
It's not reacting to what type of market
we're in now.
What it really is, is about predicting
what type of market we're going to be in
in the future.
And building your ideas and building your
portfolio around what your expectations
are for the future.
It's going to become very clear that the
market itself is a discounting mechanism
and a forward-looking indicator.
Because all professional traders are using
the market as a proxy to predict the
future.
Now, if you're a retail trader who
predicts to what's happening now,
all you're actually doing is providing the
liquidity for professional guys who
predicted where we were going to be at
this stage at some point in the past.
What you've got to train your mind into is
to predicting the future.
And that's the professional trader
approach.
And that's what we're going to move on to
now.
The first stage of idea generation starts
at the macroeconomic level, at the very
top, and then we work our way down.
So, the first thing we're going to do in
idea generation is to work out where we
think the market is going to be in a
year's time.
Once we've got that, we can take positions
now, because the market is being used as a
proxy now for expectations in one year.
Okay, let's move on to video number nine
and really start to define the process of
idea generation by starting at the macro
level, and then we can work our way down.
I'll see you in video nine.
If you want to watch over any of the
videos again, just go back and keep these
principles in mind that you've learned
from video one to video seven,
and try to get the definitions of the
systematic asset selection process and
bull and bear markets as defined by
professional traders in your mind,
and just make sure this is all set in
stone and hard-coded, because these
principles are going to serve as a very
important foundation as we move forward.
See you in video nine.